wonderful to have you here your Yale
undergrad yes class of 73 the class of
73 last time when I saw the interview
that you did you did it with that gray
you compared a bit class of 73 or around
that time in sensibilities with today's
Yale College would you would you feel
uncomfortable doing that again I have a
limp it's it's it's somewhere between
anecdotal and systematic database so
it's a limited number of interactions
and it end and maybe things have changed
much in a year to year but when I was
going to Yale anyone who had any talent
was did not include me at the time
either was becoming a doctor or a lawyer
and a lawyer not to be a paid mercenary
for clients but a lawyer to be someone
who would apply the law in a positive
way make changes for the better for the
country so it's much more like a doctor
than today's lawyers who are more like I
don't know para para military and it's a
so you think that all the today's
college students tend to be less
oriented toward well just my just my my
sampling last year everyone's going to
work for a hedge fund or Morgan Stanley
or something and I just and the smartest
people too so I having come out of
finance I had a very jaundiced point of
view but they stand on prejudice but
based on 25 years of experience as to
the social benefits if any or social
detriments in my view to smart people
becoming financial engineers
quote-unquote as opposed to real
engineers real doctors or judges or
something so I have a yeah is it
prejudice if you're consistent
experience direct and indirect is that a
certain type of group of people deal
with life in a certain way
I don't think it is after a while so if
it can be if if you have self fulfilling
prophecy issues but I think if there's
consistent in direct experience and I
don't think it's reg adduce and so I
have a at least a non-presidential
observation can maybe I can be contested
but nonetheless it's important
observation so from from Yale you went
to Harvard Business School and actually
there's an interesting you're talking
about excellence excellence when I heard
you use that I think with used to praise
moral excellence idea that was a and and
and one aspect of mind of ending up at
business school it's rather humorous
actually I suppose is that I actually
toyed with going into the ministry but
in talking about excellence excellence
we want excellence but we didn't want
perfectionism and I was perfectionistic
so I decided that that a I would have to
take the responsibility of what might
happen an eternity to a group of souls
which I wasn't sure I wanted to take her
also i looked at the things like Gospels
of a gospel of luke and I looked at the
engine junctions that Jesus had for his
followers and Anna i would say literal
some people would say simplistic way
applied those and decided that was not
my bag either having grown up in upper
middle-class comfort I so so so you turn
to do it so you went to Harvard Business
School have a whole career but then you
returned after your retirement then you
turn to divinity schools after you
couldn't do so much harm that's right we
didn't need to act right employed if I
glutted myself from another's flesh no I
oh yeah so after a while like I tired of
feasting um I so I went to Harvard
Business School and I had you know and
anyone could get in back then it really
it really was a lot he's much easier and
that's not an understatement it really
was not hard to get in and ended up
gravitating to finance cos finance
required no common sense whatsoever a
certain sneakiness maybe but no common
sense and so I ended up going to finance
and and what to and the life and
casualty and their bond investment
department until my then wife and now
Seether she could leave Hartford or
wickedly parkford so being young and
foolish I said well maybe this has a
chance i went and i ended up joining the
private placement area at a wonderful
firm called kuhn loeb the first of many
I've word for to go under some summin
summin with better sort of optics and
others so anyway that's I I got into
Investment Banking sort of i meandered
in but your idealism which would which
you read those Gospels and we have
idealism that prevented you and to go
into ministry didn't quite leave you as
you as you enter the world of finance
you ended up at Enron can you tell a
little bit about how you or how you got
there what you did there and why why
were you that fly in of Android and how
right right well basically I was fired
for my previous job where my boss
announced I had a quote on economic
attachment to quality unquote much
budget which at first he won't Bleek's
that sounds so stupid i was searching
pretty good about that almost in i
realize this is the worst thing you
could say about anyone and you know
said took my quixotic approach elsewhere
why quixotic approach of course was just
basic honesty I mean it was I mean in
other words what's perfectionistic how
do we define perfectionistic and
perfectionistic obviously might be
various elements of the Sermon on the
Mount but perfectionistic in business
unless you unless and less you are quite
lucky or quite smart ends up being
whether or not you are basically honest
and that's when your motivation becomes
so important because you either have to
have motivation as a result of religion
or family conditioning or you might say
philosophy where it were as a business
philosophy you've come to certain
conclusions about what works in a long
term and I ended up having at least a
little bit of the of the religion
although it was it was pretty far afield
in some ways a lot of the family
conditioning where I didn't want to put
a blot on the family discussion and
ultimately a philosophical attitude
where I reconciled in my own mind at
least my own satisfaction the creation
of value as its understand surely
economic terms through adherence to
certain basic live let live do unto
others within a group of people within
your own corporation and that's that
ended up what you were what you try to
implement in spinnaker will come to this
but before we go to spinnaker your NY he
was adorable I've been so I'd been
basically fired from a job and so I hung
out a shingle and and did my corporate
finance consulting services I didn't
want to be paid by transaction because
what very often tends to happen not
certainly but most people you could get
paid by transaction by transaction or
usually you actually know a lot more
than the client the client thinks they
know but they don't and so that can
easily be turned into a situation where
you're just gleefully stealing money
from clients but if you're really a lot
smarter than they are you can do it
without them
really knowing and that happens a lot in
investment banking and we're both the
trading side and the lesson of banking
side and God help us now in affecting
entire banks which is why we haven't
really fixed our problems but anyway i
was paid only for yearly services which
is much less lucrative but happier
there's no conflict between on the
client I don't have to worry about
maintaining separation you know playing
any information games as a result of
course no one wants that niche because
you can't make huge amounts of money and
so I had no competition to speak of but
I was doing that for about two years
after I got fired my might never wants
me to say that but that's what happened
and one of the clients I dealt with was
Enron because I helped finance them you
know when they were put together when
they were a merger so what year are we
talking about now ah that was I started
working with them in like 93 okay and
then in early 94 I started to sort of
they were then all they were the
absolute top Ops will talk that's right
i think i'm sure fortune probably had
them on it's the most admired
cooperation in the country so i went to
work for their CFO because they were
getting proposals from banks and
investment banks every type of proposal
coming over the transom every day and
then the guy was just sort of swamped
and I you know when he asked me to help
them just figure out what may basic
sense I was doing that for about six
months before I ended up working on this
project where they were going to take
all their international pipelines and
power projects and roll them up into a
public company himself half of it to to
the public and ended up working on that
forum I guess nine months so when I
heard you tell the story you were flying
in a small jet to Argentina yeah and
then you had
epiphany of sorts nasty epiphany was a
nasty pic nasty money or something it's
a we were flying down to Argentina to
look at our Argentine pipeline and the
chief operating officer was talking
talking up some of his projects he
wanted to sell my little public company
and I think he was expecting basically
that he would be able to sell it to us
on about a ten percent nominal after tax
discount rate which is the sort of thing
you would expect for a very low-risk
project in the United States as opposed
to you know Dominican Republic where
they occasionally pay their bills but
often don't and you know we I wish is
where the property or whatever I bet
that's where it was he was talking up he
was talking up the Dominican Republic
project and saying how great it was and
literally all I said was well from the
point of views of EPP the little public
company we never got any further than
that because he launched into a tirade
for the next 45 minutes you know we us
my me and then he started screaming
these things little things bulging and
and anybody clear that any such talk was
was beyond anathema that it was that it
was going to be dealt with in the in the
most violent way so that was about a
month after we went public I said oh my
lord so he that was an end run guy and
you were right so I mean he's a little
bit the relationship between this
between company that you were running
which was kind of Enron 51% own all
right excellent point okay and rinone
51-percent of Enron global power and
pipelines the public the minority owned
40 90 percenter so it was highly
improper
for the majority owner to start to
browbeat an officer whose loyalties must
remain with the minority owner my
minority owners and it was just
amazingly improper behavior both
psychologically as well as legally and
the first of many attempts to abuse the
process basically to benefit the parent
and run at the expense of the minority
and so is this the case in point where
well who is there to to to look out for
the interest of the shareholders in the
consistent management you try to do that
and you were effectively shut down is
that because that will happen yes I'm
completely I know it's very normal and
complicated but basically that was the
starting point and then whenever Enron
needed to make quarterly earnings which
there was always a a last-minute mad
dash to get a penny over the analyst
estimates the last couple of weeks
they're always looking for things and
they would you know try to done us with
this expense that really was properly
there's and make it ours and of course
if you take a 10 million dollar expense
which Enron should pay and they make my
little company pay you do the math
instead of having to pay 10 million they
pay in effect 5.1 million so they've
gained 14 in the 4.9 million and even
multiply that about 10 times over that's
what they are trying to do and either I
was negotiating with the CEO of Enron
was also on the EPP board or I was
negotiating with my direct boss who was
the CFO of actually he's the president
of EPP who was and he was also employed
by Enron so it and he determined my
bonus the it sounds stupid but here's
the thing is that i thought when i
joined the
the subsidiary said well they can't fool
around with this they they live and die
by being able to take these companies
public if they foul this up they're
going to drastically limit their access
to future such spin-offs but I hadn't
really counted on the ledger domain of
the lawyers who involved because with
appropriate disclosure or non disclosure
you can cover up cover over any abuses
and so it you know that's I mean that's
why when I say them at least in my in my
career I didn't do it deal with
engineering I didn't deal with a lot of
disciplines like that I dealt with
finance and in finance if you're
basically honest when i started in
finance in 1975 that was typical and but
by the time I left that was almost
unique and I think of I think of Al
Gore's frog and the slowly heating water
and and and and the in this case the
whole environment was shifting from
basic ethics to basic lack of ethics now
what tell about that shift now as you
look at this shift now or as you have
experienced in for where you were
sitting why was that shift what what
caused it what what motivated it what
propelled it well I think there was a
basic ideological shift in the whole
country in that and and to a certain
extent we have many benefits economic
benefits but there are some downsides
the basic ideological shift is that
government is superfluous and that
basically private enterprise can do
everything it can do it better and the
Martin magic of the market will will
assure that everything is perfectly
allocated and because of reputation
concerns people always do the right
thing and you know
and unfortunately even the regulator's
believe that so what you had was the
illusion of regulation worse than no
regulation if you have no regulation
you're safer than if you have the
illusion regulation just like if you
have better to have no laws than to have
laws which which then highly paid
lawyers can figure out how to get around
because then people think their laws
there aren't laws in a lot of cases you
know my father used to be a lawyer he's
about the only lawyer ever knew that
didn't make a lot of money and I thought
about that and why would anyone pay a
lawyer a lot of money to basically tell
you to follow in spirit and in to the
letter with the law is that's not you
pay a lawyer for you pay your lawyer to
get around the law so it's it's it
really is one of these things that just
shocks me and I'm basically a moderate
Republican but it's it's it was a shock
to me that anyone would think that we
didn't need the SEC for example you know
to police what was going on because
without countervailing pressures like
that people will be tempted to do the
wrong thing because there's because an
asymmetric payoff so one one element
authority one element was kind of a
large framework of thinking about
economy as a whole kind of in a sense of
medical on undiluted belief in a
completely free market connected with
that was pushed toward their
deregulation right right right and some
of the part of the deregulation you know
as had immediately in long-term
beneficial effects like the really the
break up the fixed rates for stock
Commission's which had prevailed for
hundreds of years before the SEC broke
that up and that took really what was
sort of a gentleman's game in terms of
investment banking and really made it
into a much more of a free-for-all which
would have been okay but for other types
of deregulation which then took
something from being sort of it might
say again an elegant slow-moving game
into
do you know a particularly huge version
of a worldwide Wrestling Federation or
something you in your interview that
I've heard before you also mentioned and
then in our conversations you mentioned
also that there's something peculiar
about the character of corporation as
opposed to partnership which lends
itself it again is that right or well
it's sort of it's slightly different
than that and that is there and that is
the big break for me it's not
corporation versus for example a general
partnership or proprietorship we have
online unlimited liability the big break
is between a privately held part
corporation and a publicly held
corporation because I know I have some
family I know people who own family
corporations where they make very long
term arrangements very enter into
long-term sorts of policies which really
are built around reputation which often
you either either coincidentally or not
question n taliyah reinforced by ethics
but they really do the right thing I
guess in the long term they expect that
if they do the wrong thing it'll come
back to haunt them maybe not next year
in five years but in the long term will
come back to haunt them that's a family
corporation they expect it to be around
for a hundred years let's assume that
you have a different situation where if
you can you know beat your estimates by
a penny by reversing various reserves
over the course of a year and convince
people that your you know your honor
your honor roll you know what's your
really blacking you're really doing just
a great detailed job blocking and
tackling when it factors fudging the
numbers but such as the public market
that most people invest in public market
are unaware of what's going on and
unaware of how little they know about
what's going on they push the stock up
and you just made fifty million bucks
well are you going to worry about 100
years from now if you just made fifty
million bucks no at least most people
are
you know I suppose if you were a value
Maximizer and you say well you know it's
50 million this year but I want to make
unlimited amounts of money and it's
based on my reputation well maybe those
people exist I never met them you know
if I make 50 million bucks this year
that's enough and I'm not going to worry
about what happens to my reputation
because a lot of times for weaker
weak-minded people you'll be able to
convince them of untruth quite plausibly
and they'll go around believing you
still of a good reputation so it's it's
anyway that's the bad that was it says
let's shift to the positive that was
limit but no I want a little stay with
bad little banged up a little bit longer
and l1 one more thing which I which I
think what we discussed which I thought
was very important and that is once you
come now to more personal character of
the decision making at one point you
talk well you mentioned well sometimes
you think well there is a there is a
there is an edge to which you come and
then there is there's nothing there's no
there's no way and there's no edge I
talk talk about there not being a name
no there's there's my experience at
least is that people it most people
assume that they will walk to the edge
of a moral precipice and look down and
see oh my god that's the result what
really happens are on some sort of egg
and it gets steeper and steeper and
steeper but they're always saying well i
can maintain my balance in spite of the
fact i'm taking more and more and more
risky actions in terms of ethics or
questionable actions and it's or else
like it's like the frog people gradually
are descending into a unstable situation
ethically terms their approach to life
and they don't even know it because
they've been either because everyone
else is similarly descending or else
because their powers of rationalization
are sufficient to offset the changing
terrain and I a lot of people it really
is what is everyone else doing it's like
alcoholics like to you know stick
together because you're not drinking
more than anyone elses
well the same way with people who have
bad ethics well I'm no worse than Joe or
feet I mean I'm you know we're all doing
the same thing so the norm so what's
defined as norm is just looking around
the room as opposed to any sort of norm
which incorporates a broader notion of
what it means to be human okay you want
to go to positive right and the positive
and the positive that's very good I
think I think we need we need the
positive positive the the the positive
side is then what what you did when you
left Enron and that is you had a well I
left I left Enron with the same time as
the the the controller and the and the
general counsel did which ended up not
being disclosed all over the same issue
in that is they wanted to take our
accounting group away from us and give
us back the cost but have them to report
to Enron and so it was one of these
ridiculous gambits and they did that
without ever disclosing any of this but
so I am the general counsel and the
controller left the same time in Sonic
October 95 and in 96 I helped a friend
start a oil and gas company mostly gas
in the gas is easier to find you know in
the Gulf at least oil and gas company
exploration company and worked there for
five years two years ago and they're
being sold to norsk hydro big Norwegian
oil and gas company and in the meantime
we had had basically a 12 12 to 1 return
to our equity holders with no debt at
the start and you know which by Silicon
Valley standards is nothing but I old by
old economy standards is a good you know
very good return
for me so it's it's a but the important
points about spinnaker is that you know
when you're starting a company there are
lots of questions well how do i
structure that and how do I look at you
know and and the good news is any time
we had any doubt about what to do I
literally said to myself what would
Enron do and we do the reverse and you
know we you know for example we were
honest in our in our disclosures to the
public we were honest in our disclosures
to our employees we made sure that the
employees knew that we were all in this
together we had a weekly meeting be 8
a.m. at Monday morning where we'd go
through everything the company was doing
with all the employees we had told them
we were not going to tell talk to them
about any impending mergers but we were
not going to have a merger in which we
were not the successor company in
control so that they didn't you know the
weeks we told them we were not going to
talk about that but not to worry and we
met it what ended up happening i believe
is is that we solve the problem that
bedeviled so many companies and that is
you might say sub optimization where
people are really just looking for their
own own good and gaming the system and
lack of information flow so basically
and employees like some of the children
I've I've met don't care what you say
they care what you do they don't care
about your mission statement and Ron had
a beautiful mission statement they care
what do you do and that's that's the
that's that's the tone if you're lying
to people or if you're engaging in
sexual harassment as a top manager
they'll see okay now I understand what
the ethics are and I'll apply them in my
own way and so we ended up with an
ethical culture of truth-telling
corporate culture and that's reason
that's important is that for most
companies the real problem is
information that is the end and making
sure information flows to the top and
information flows back
again and that is a huge problem in most
most corporations especially
slow-growing corporations as people
start to battle it out and we felt that
was that was the most important thing we
could do is establish that type of
environment and we were willing to work
hard to do that and there are some
trade-offs because if you because in the
short term and if you're really
short-term oriented which most a lot of
public companies are better to sort of
fuzzy up some your disclosure of their
problems or you know cover it over
because all you you know if you can just
get through a hard period then surely
your business will will rise and you and
you will never have had to talk about
that well it blew up or something and
you know it's it's it's so there so you
have to so there has to be bite to the
concept for it to be respected so that's
one one area the other area you talked
about a kind of development of of your
employees the idea that well no matter
what happened with the company you
wanted them to write right then if it
from having i haven't been fair we the
startups are notoriously risky a lot of
them fail we wanted to make sure that if
we failed that each and every employee
that dedicated at least a portion their
career to us sacrificed other
opportunities would not regret having
become so we made sure that we gave each
and every employee either the tools or
the training or both to be worth more
with each passing year than they were
before and it was and became our problem
to make sure they were compensated
appropriately so we didn't want to have
someone in the slot and leave them there
we wanted to challenge them which would
then challenged us by being better all
the time and what kind of that that
seemed so noble and what what our did
what were the difficulties in the in the
process of doing that this you mentioned
48 hours of migraine at one point I am
well yeah there are difficulties but I
tend to worry too much and in my case I
was worried that I might have some lack
of perfection which would somehow costs
on my employees a lot of money because
we had them compensated with company
stock and options and for a lot of them
it was probably exclusive of their house
eighty percent or more than that worth
and so I was always worried that I if I
didn't handle things perfectly somehow
it might come back to bite them it
wouldn't be a problem for me but it'd be
a huge problem for them one of one of
the issues there many issues and is with
weaknesses in our financial system but
one of them is that most of the people
who invest most of the public money
really have no idea what they're doing
and you know it's not a Warren Buffett
will be able to or Peter Lynch will be
able to assess a company strategy assess
the ability of management and the
capital structure to affect that
strategy and make a reasoned decision
but that's one in a million most of
people managing public's money you know
only know whether you've beaten your
quarterly estimates if they have you
beaten them they buy if you say if you
haven't they say they sell and sometimes
they sell a lot very quickly if we had
missed our quarterly estimates I think
our stock would have been down twenty
thirty percent a week we came close to
missing our estimates one time one
quarter we came it was just the last day
that we made our estimates and I had a
48-hour migraine and worrying about that
some companies can create estimates that
they can beat it will and the way they
do that is merely by creating bogus
reserves which are then reversed
whenever they want the earnings so they
smooth out which is otherwise a volatile
earnings stream creating a false sense
of calm
a false sense of low risk and so in our
case you couldn't do that we couldn't
both by I don't want to Pat myself on
the back both will do both by in clinic
personal inclination and also by the the
youth of the company we couldn't do that
we actually had to live or die by our
estimates that here's the next problem
and that is while we projected
mediocrity to the outside world that
demanded excellence internally if you
project mediocrity occasionally you
won't even achieve that maybe it's only
five percent of the time but you know
this well and this well and this will
all have problems and maybe there's only
a 1000 chance but you'll miss mediocrity
but if you ever miss an estimate it's
it's felt to be sort of a violation of
whatever covenant exists between the
investors and the company because most
of them cannot even begin to understand
any explanation and don't have the time
or inclination to do so so it in my case
that was the problem was was I ended up
it worrying too much however i think the
the course of the company was clear and
the attitudes were clear and the end
they ended up continuing after i retired
after five years at the company loved it
by sandwich 48-hour migraine now be a
coronary in 10 years i don't need the
money money doesn't further money will
not correlate with with more happiness
so I'm off to divinity scope well thank
you Jim we'll take a break for about 10
minutes and then we'll return for
general discussion